[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors pour moi la plus grande chance le
vrai succès c'est d'être devenu
tellement bon dans une activité que ça
nous épanouit au quotidien finalement de
se retrouver dans ce cercle ou soit on
est épanoui dans une activité et par la
force des choses on va devenir bon ou
alors on est déjà doué dans une activité
on a un petit talent et grâce à la
maîtrise de celle-ci on va être épanouie
et cerise sur le gâteau cette activité
nous rapporte de l'argent on a tout
gagné on est épanoui on maîtrise un
domaine et en plus on gagne de l'argent
c'est parfait
et on pourrait croire que le plus long
et le plus difficile sur cette route
vers le succès et l'épanouissement c'est
de devenir excellent dans un domaine par
exemple si je vais être écrivain il va
me falloir beaucoup de travail
d'écriture et beaucoup de temps avant de
sortir des bons livres même si c'est une
activité qui m'épanouit et dans laquelle
j'ai un petit talent de base ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps
mais moi je pense pas je pense pas ça
pour moi c'est pas le cas pour moi le
plus difficile c'était pas de devenir un
expert dans un domaine mais c'était
d'abord de trouver ma voie
la première étape
je savais pas ce que j'allais faire de
ma vie j'étais pas particulièrement doué
dans une activité et il y avait aucune
activité qui m'épanouissait plus que ça
au lycée je savais pas ce que j'allais
faire plus tard comme métier
pendant mes études supérieures je savais
toujours pas non plus alors que j'étais
déjà bien engagé dans un cursus
universitaire et aujourd'hui sept ans
plus tard c'est toujours un peu flou
et
je sais que ce cas là c'est pas le cas
de tout le monde je connais et je pense
qu'on connaît tous des personnes au
lycée qui savaient déjà quel était leur
voix elles sont rares ces personnes mais
elles ont énormément de chance on a
l'impression qu'elle se pose pas de
question à ce sujet là que tout est très
clair dans leur tête et des personnes
comme moi qui sont pas attirées par un
domaine en particulier quand on se
compare avec ces gens-là
c'est pas forcément agréable parce qu'on
a l'impression que on a loupé quelque
chose à côté d'eux
je
j'aimerais savoir justement dans la
salle
qui au lycée savait déjà ce qu'il allait
faire comme métier et était persuadé de
son choix et aujourd'hui et encore perçu
et puis persuadé de son choix lever la
main ce qui ce qui savent pas beaucoup
je croyais il y en a quatre cinq maximum
ok
donc la majorité des gens sont comme moi
et c'est vrai que c'est difficile pour
nous de choisir une seule chose de
vraiment choisir une seule profession ou
une seule voix
qu'on va suivre pendant toute notre vie
finalement c'est un peu comme un mariage
faut pouvoir l'assumer ce choix c'est
comme si à 17 ans on me disait ok
maintenant tu vas choisir ton ou ta
conjointe la personne avec qui tu vas
passer le reste de ta vie il y a pas eu
de période d'essai de trois mois pour
savoir si ça te plaisait vraiment tu as
pas eu le temps de te connaître pour
savoir si c'était avec ce genre de
personne que tu t'endors le mieux et ce
genre de mariage se faisait à l'époque
mais on a changé d'époque comme pour les
métiers aujourd'hui rares sont les
personnes qui restent avec le même
partenaire toute leur vie et je pense
que le problème
de notre indécision et de notre besoin
de changement
vient du fait que on a beaucoup trop de
choix
en tout cas moi c'est comme ça que je le
vois le problème ne venait certainement
pas d'une fainéantise de ma part j'ai
toujours été de bonne volonté pour
travailler et pour faire des études en
réalité je cherchais toujours le truc
qui allait donner du sens à ma vie et me
plonger dans cette voie
je me disais que peut-être qu'en
devenant docteur j'allais prouver de la
satisfaction aider les gens peut-être
qu'en devenant boulanger j'allais
m'épanouir dans un travail manuel ou
peut-être qu'en faisant de la politique
vous allez pouvoir changer le monde
je cherchais chercher tout le temps
j'étais curieux
peut-être même un peu trop curieux un
jour je tombe sur un article qui parlait
des personnes comme moi des personnes
qui sont intéressées par de nombreux
domaines mais qui ont du mal à en
choisir un seul et comme ça j'ai appris
que ce que j'avais ça s'appelait La
Malédiction de Devinci de Vinci comme le
peintre de la Renaissance qui était
aussi ingénieur architecte scientifique
et musiciens aussi il faisait beaucoup
de choses et le nom m'a vraiment fait
rire et pourtant
l'article pointait du doigt mon problème
et si vous voulez on va voir rapidement
si vous aussi vous êtes des maudits de
de Vinci le premier symptôme est-ce que
vous avez est-ce que vous êtes incapable
à faire une seule activité à la fois à
chaque fois que vous faites une activité
il y en a toujours une autre à côté pour
vous faire de l'oeil et vous êtes dans
le changement constant est-ce que le
deuxième symptôme
pour vous choisir une seule activité ça
veut dire renoncer à plein
d'opportunités et ça c'est le cauchemar
des maudits de Vinci on a trop peur de
passer à côté des opportunités ensuite
est-ce que on pourrait dire de vous que
vous êtes curieux de tout mais expert en
rien ça veut dire que vous en savez un
peu sur beaucoup de domaines vous
maîtrisez aucun domaine en profondeur
et le dernier symptôme est-ce que vous
avez l'impression d'avoir perdu du temps
parce que à force de vous disperser dans
toutes ces activités
vous retrouvez nulle part et vous savez
toujours pas quel est votre vocation
je sais pas vous mais ça c'est
exactement moi de mes 18 à mes 24 ans je
faisais tout ce qui me passait par la
tête j'allais où mon enthousiasme me
portait donc après le lycée je suis allé
en fac de langue à côté je prenais des
cours de montage vidéo et de graphisme
je donnais des cours de français en
ligne j'avais lancé une chaîne Youtube
où je parlais de mode et de et de sport
pour faire comme les youtubeurs que je
regardais à l'époque
j'ai écrit un scénario de manga tout est
prêt il manque plus que les dessins là
aujourd'hui
j'ai je me suis lancé dans
l'apprentissage d'une nouvelle langue en
autodidacte à côté de celle que
j'apprenais dans mes études
il faut savoir que à cette période là je
faisais tout en même temps j'étais
persuadé que si j'arrivais à tout bien
faire en même temps j'allais avoir des
opportunités fantastiques et c'était
impossible pour moi d'imagerie
d'imaginer abandonner une de ses idées
j'avais trop peur de rater des
opportunités et je me disais si jamais
il y a une idée qui prend pas il y en
aura toujours d'autres au cas où j'en
allais avoir des idées de secours
forcément il y a des idées qui
fonctionnent mieux que d'autres j'avais
notamment une petite chaîne YouTube dans
laquelle j'ai des personnes à prendre
des langues étrangères et qui me
rapportaient un SMIC à côté de mes
études et ça ça m'a permis de faire un
tri j'ai compris à ce moment-là que
c'était souvent la viabilité financière
d'une idée qu'il faisait qu'elle allait
prendre le pas sur toutes les autres
donc je me suis concentré sur cette
activité naturellement et j'ai abandonné
tout le reste
mais comme tout bon maudit de Vinci à un
moment ça m'ennuie alors j'arrête
et je me mets à faire plein de nouvelles
choses
je finis par tester le salariat dans un
atelier de sculpture qui fait aussi des
vidéos sur internet je pars faire du
stop en costume trois pièces avec des
potes pour traverser la France et
j'ouvre un restaurant en livraison à
Nice
voilà je vous ai dit que je faisais
vraiment tout ce qui me passait par la
tête
mais bon ça commence à faire ça commence
à faire long là ça fait plus de 7 ans
que je cherche ma voie sans succès
jusqu'à ce que j'ai une grosse prise de
conscience récemment
je réalise que
qui me suivait depuis le début depuis le
moment où je me suis posé la question en
quittant le lycée c'était la vidéo
du scénario de manga à l'atelier de
sculpture à mon activité d'indépendant
en ligne au restaurant tout avait un
rapport avec la vidéo depuis le début ma
voix était juste la sous mes yeux et je
me rendais même pas compte
et c'est vrai que maintenant on y pense
en
il y a que quand je fais des vidéos que
je me sens aussi bien c'est c'est ce qui
me permet c'est ce qui me donne une
sensation une vraie sensation de
maîtrise et ce qui me permet de
m'expliquer de m'exprimer sans filtre de
me sentir utile
quand je monte ou quand j'écris des
vidéos c'est vraiment des moments à part
dans ma vie
et en fait pendant toutes ces années
sans forcément m'en rendre compte j'ai
fait naturellement ce qui m'épanouissait
plus faire des vidéos
à force d'en faire je suis devenu bon et
cerise sur le gâteau c'est ce qui me
permet de gagner ma vie
après plus de 7 ans de recherche et de
questionnement
j'ai réussi par provoquer ce que je
considère comme étant la plus grande
chance trouver sa voie
j'ai réussi à trouver ma voie et
j'aimerais vous aider à avoir cette même
chance
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous partager
quelques pistes
pour
pour que vous y arrivez aussi
la première étape
c'est
si tout intérêt fais tout ce qui
t'intéresse la première étape c'est
d'essayer un maximum d'activités il faut
surtout pas rester passif si on n'a pas
encore la chance d'avoir trouvé sa voie
il faut aller la chercher je saurais
jamais si j'aime conduire des camions de
7 tonnes pendant 10 heures temps je suis
pas dans le camion à le conduire je peux
l'imaginer
je peux penser que ça me plairait comme
métier mais je serai jamais vraiment
tant que j'ai pas essayé
dans l'idéal il faut faire tout ce qui
nous passe par la tête suivre son
enthousiasme
pour ça il faut s'écouter il faut pas se
mettre de barrières il faut pas juger
ses envies il faut tout oser dans
l'idéal le test d'une nouvelle passion
ça nous prendra deux semaines à un mois
avant qu'on se rende compte que c'est
pas fait pour nous
dans le pire des cas avec les études par
exemple ça peut prendre cinq ans avant
de se rendre compte que c'est pas fait
pour nous
ça fait beaucoup de temps perdu à
essayer de s'en trouver et c'est pas
agréable comme situation de se rendre
compte qu'on a fait le mauvais choix et
c'est à ce moment là
qu'on peut tomber dans le piège de la
comparaison avec les autres
parce que quand on n'a pas encore trouvé
sa voie et qu'on se compare avec les
autres on peut se sentir embarrassé
parce que telle personne du même âge que
toi ou plus jeune que toi peut-être
qu'elle a pas eu besoin de passer par
toutes ces phases de test peut-être que
là elle est en ligne droite dans son
cursus universitaire l'année prochaine
elle aura terminé ses études et elle va
commencer le métier qu'elle aura
toujours voulu faire peut-être que toi
au contraire tu as déjà dû changer de
filière plusieurs fois peut-être que tu
empruntes une voix qui met un peu plus
de temps à porter ses fruits et c'est
une situation difficile à expliquer à
tes proches ou peut-être simplement que
tu sais toujours pas quoi faire et que
tu es toujours perdu
et dans ces moments là il faut que
trouver sa voie c'est pas une course
se connaître c'est pour moi la plus
belle chose qui puisse nous arriver
c'est l'immense chance de s'épanouir
dans la vie alors autant que ça se fasse
sans mensonges et sans pression des
autres ça prendra plus de temps mais une
fois qu'on aura réussi à savoir ce qu'on
veut vraiment faire dans sa vie grâce au
test et à l'introspection et à
l'introspection on a tout gagné parce
que là on est sûr que c'est la bonne
voie
c'est celle qui vient du plus profond de
nous elle a eu le temps de mûrir dans
notre tête
on la questionné on la challengeait avec
d'autres possibilités et elle est
toujours là parce que c'est elle notre
voix
les personnes qui avaient l'air d'avoir
trouvé leur voix très tôt ont pu très
bien se mentir à elle-même nous on voit
que leur parcours scolaire on sait pas
ce qui se passe dans leur tête peut-être
que au fond d'elle elle savait très bien
que continuer tel master c'était pas
fait pour eux mais ils ont pu persuader
que si c'était bien ça leur voix et
qu'il avait trouvé du premier coup
peut-être que plus tard
leur mensonge deviendra tellement
insoutenable
qui vont faire une crise de la
quarantaine et qui décideront de changer
complètement de vie on sait pas c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas se comparer
on démarre en tréteaux son
questionnement quand on entre dans la
vie étudiante
certes on peut perdre un peu de temps
sur le court terme mais au moins on se
met pas des œillères on essaie pas de
cacher la vérité ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas faire de longues études ça veut
juste dire qu'il faut être honnête avec
soi-même et pas se mentir pour devenir
un adulte qui sait ce qu'il aime et
quelle est sa voix
je voudrais conclure tout ça en disant
que finalement il n'y a pas de solution
magique il faut jamais arrêter d'essayer
de chercher sa voix tant qu'on n'a pas
trouvé et il faut passer ces décourager
par la comparaison après sur votre
chemin vous pourrez rencontrer des
indicateurs qui vous aideront à savoir
si vous êtes si vous êtes sur la bonne
voie
par exemple parmi toutes les activités
que vous faites peut-être que il y a un
point commun qui revient très souvent il
faut pas hésiter à creuser dans cette
direction
l'enthousiasme ne montre pas toujours la
bonne voie mais si nous emmène toujours
dans la même direction c'est qu'il a
quelque chose à nous faire comprendre
moi c'est comme ça que j'ai trouvé ma
voie le point commun entre toutes les
activités que je faisais c'était la
vidéo
ensuite il y a les mauvaises expériences
qui sont souvent les plus bénéfiques
c'est pas du temps perdu il faut pas le
voir comme ça c'est tentatives raté nous
permettent de savoir ce qu'on a pas
envie de faire dans la vie et ça c'est
déjà une énorme piste une excellente
piste
enfin si vous avez un profil tout Chatou
que vous avez besoin de constamment être
stimulé d'apprendre de progresser pensez
aux activités qui ont une marge de
progression infinie généralement ça
concerne les activités créatives moi
j'adore les activités créatives parce
qu'avec elle j'ai l'impression d'avoir
aucune limite de progression par exemple
avec le montage vidéo et le storytelling
j'aurais jamais fini de m'améliorer
j'aurais jamais fini d'apprendre ces
compétences il y aura toujours de
nouvelles idées à l'infini et c'est ça
qui m'accroche avec cette voix c'est ça
qui fait qu'elle m'en aura jamais
enfin j'ai quand même envie de terminer
en disant que il faut aussi être prêt à
l'idée
que tout ça peut changer quand on a
trouvé sa voie
ça ne garantit pas qu'on aura envie de
la suivre toute notre vie
parce qu'on est humain on peut se
tromper on peut toujours en apprendre
davantage sur le monde sur nous-mêmes
il faut garder en tête que trouver sa
voix
n'éteindra probablement jamais notre
curiosité
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]